Welcome, everybody, to another book where I do my best to answer your questions. Remember, if you're new here, do a lot of going to remove this.
Remember, if you have questions to either use the chat and chat them in or when I'm done with the submitted questions, you can unmute yourself and ask the question if you so desire.
All right. Remember also that any changes, updates that I think are necessary for everybody to see will be in the member site main homepage of the member site where you can see any new announcements.
Okay, first question.
You've been using the Atelier Robin now for many months. Do you still think it's the best machine on the market? My brother wants to get a right machine.
You recall, we have switched to mainly recommending the Atelier Robin machine over the true right back since last September, October, when it came out.
Yes, there was some bumps along the road to begin with, but now we haven't had any issues with them at all.
Do I think it's a better machine? Yes, because it does put out three times the voltage.
Do I think that it is the better machine because you can run harmonics on it? To me, that's the best piece of it.
Also, you can run higher frequencies where you had to use the foot bath with the true right to get the higher frequencies.
The Atelier Robin lets you get up to the higher frequencies that Royal Life actually used.
So it has those three advantages. The disadvantage though, I would say, is that it is larger. It's bulkier.
Patrick Robin may be working on changing that and redoing it just for us.
I've given him my request of how to reform the machine in different ways and things that we don't need and things that I think will be better and improvements and he may be making those changes in the next fold out.
So if a person, we don't always recommend the Atelier Robin, so we've had people that you don't want it to write because they have a history of it to write.
And that's okay, I still, because I think the trip is still a great machine.
And then, or we've had people that, hey, I travel a lot and I'm on the road all the time.
And then getting a true right makes a little bit more sense because it's much smaller, easier to travel with easier to put to wrap in a couple sweatshirts that put in a suitcase to keep it safe.
And then is the Atelier Robin.
So there's pros and cons to each unit as far as having it at home and using it at home using it overnight.
I think until we are all with the best machine, we have a number of people have both.
They may start it out with the trip and they add in the Atelier Robin with the, you know, use one at night to use one during the day so they haven't two different rooms.
So that makes sense to, of course, there's cost to it, so I understand that that's that was doable for everybody.
If a person is calling and says I just want to get the best one for me, it depends again, partly depends on what their personal conditions are.
So, you know, if they just want one for home to use it, you know, the kids got the flu or something like that.
I think the Atelier Robin is much better because if you're really using it mainly to kill pathogens being dealing with the mode here, dealing with bronchitis or dealing with two infections or dealing with your infections or something like that.
Running 11 harmonics is better and I wrote all the programs are the Atelier Robin true right, if I did not write all the programs of the true right.
So I had complete control over all the programs and all the frequencies. So those are those are our program. So I feel much more comfortable with it.
Next question. Do you recommend a particular store or pharmacy to purchase safe. I've been getting my supply from a place in India that is recommended to me by a good friend who's a pharmacist.
She said a lot of our medication from the US comes from India. This particular place is a good customer service. So they seem reputable. However, in recent weeks, I've been reading more about how I've erected and be contaminated with the various elements like mRNA.
Have it only knows if that is true because there is so much consenting information in line. Do you think it'd be worth it to have a supply tested for purity or is that overkill?
Well, I think it would be worth it to have a supply tested for purity. I just don't know how you could do that unless you're old, you're old by okay. So I know that's just not to be real doable.
But the first question, I do not have a particular store pharmacy that I have ordered I've erected from because I don't have I have not used either.
Do I have a supply of men's at home in case of a catastrophe. Yes.
And as I've erected part of that supply. Yes, but there's not a lot of capsules in my supply. I don't want to. I don't even know what it is. I don't even look at it when I came.
Well, this store or something like that. Where I got it.
So place of life. Have I heard that I've erected has been tainted with different things. Yes, I've heard that same thing. Do I believe that it's true? Well, I don't know, I don't know if that's true.
But I would say I would doubt it. So remember what I've always said is I've erected is still a draw. So, you know, it still has side effects, even if it isn't tainted with something.
I don't trust the pharmaceutical companies as far as I could throw up and I would agree that it could be tainted with the various elements.
It's that I just don't know and I don't know how we would know that.
I wish I had a better answer for you. I'm still experiencing frequent panic attacks from Lyme disease, brain inflammation and low estrogen.
So, what are your thoughts on me trying some hypervere oxygen treatments for the Lyme disease and breast cancer? It hopes that it will help you rid of the panic attacks.
One concern I have is that I have read it can cause those with Lyme to hurt, you have a hurt cyber reaction, the hurts badly.
So, hypermeric oxygen is oxygen under pressure, which you're in an oxygen tank.
And it is highly beneficial for your brain. It can kill Lyme disease. And the reason why it works is if you had a current bacterial meaning.
So, the Lyme disease by definition is a combination of Relya burgodorphia bacteria and other co-infections.
Some of the other co-infections are virus, not even bacteria, and some of them are not gram negative bacteria.
You get a, you get a first cyber reaction from mainly from the death of gram negative bacteria because they have lipopolysaccharides in their cell membrane.
And when you liberate them by killing a lot of them quickly, you can feel really it.
And so, that being said, can hypermeric oxygen, if you have current Relya in your brain, cause a herxabor? Yes.
Well, how would I know that or not? There's no test for that. You can't do a lab or do I have Relya in my brain lab?
If you did a Relya burgodorphia IgM antibody test, and it was positive, you could get a good clue that you have a current infection of Relya, but it doesn't mean that it's in the brain.
However, if you killed quickly, no matter where it is, you could get a herxabor reaction anyhow.
So, I would say, I would say to go for it, but do shorter sessions to begin with.
So, typically a hypermeric oxygen treatment session is going to be at least one hour, 60 minutes long.
Sometimes, depending on where you go, it can be a 90-minute session or even a two hour session, but typically it's going to start with a 60-minute session.
If you tell the practitioner your dilemma with live disease that you want to start shorter, there's no harm in doing only a 15-minute session.
Well, how am I just doing a shorter session? You know, three times a week or something, and see how you tolerate it.
If you tolerate it well, certainly a 15-minute session, three times a week is going to cause a horrible live disease that's going to put you in a crippling position for a period of days.
That's going to be a short enough experience that's not going to cause that much like a polysaccharide liberation.
If you do have Borrelia currently in your body, remember many times people with chronic live disease are suffering the effects of the chronic live that may not have living Borrelia in their body anymore.
That's the majority of the cases. They are just dealing with autoimmune issues that, you know, that Borrelia left behind.
So they have antibodies to do a little tissue, they have antichimals, priming, et cetera, in the brain, and they're dealing with those effects.
They may not have the existence of Borrelia bacteria.
So if you tolerate the 15 minutes, three times a week, then go to 30 minutes.
Oh, I'm tolerating that well, then go up to 45 minutes. You can work your way up and make sure that you don't hurt.
That's a good way to do it.
The positive is that the hyperbaric option is good for breast cancer, it's good for your brain.
If you have antibodies to neural tissue, it's really good for that. It helps clear the brain.
It's only got positives, except for that piece of it could actually kill pathogens.
And if those pathogens are grabbed negative bacteria, it could hurt, of course.
So that's the thing you just got to go slow with.
I typically make a coffee concentrate for my coffee animals and came across information of cold brewing, which might be a more convenient way to make the concentrate.
Then I read some information on your website about essentially a cold brew process or concentrate.
Is this still something you would recommend?
Yes, absolutely, because if you're going to make enough coffee and a concentrate for the week, yes, you could do it that way.
The information I was reading online about cold brewing in general says that that it increases the caffeine content and decreases the acid.
So would the lower acid content make the cold brewing option less attractive? No, it's the caffeine that makes it attractive.
That is why you're using the coffee animal coffee for doing coffee animals. It's very, very light roast. You wouldn't, I don't know if anybody's ever tried drinking the coffee animal coffee, but it is horrible.
It's horrible tasting.
You wouldn't want to drink it. It's super, super high-capita taste or excuse me.
So the reason why it is so lightly roasted is because you want the higher-capita content.
That's what makes it more attractive for coffee animals.
So this is just fine to do it this way.
You like the US enzymes TVGO or the EGCG?
I looked it up online and came across pure encapsulations. That's a different company TVGO.
Is this the same? Both companies have the register name TVGO with the R symbol, which makes me wonder. It is.
So pure encapsulations buys their green tea extract from US enzymes.
Actually, US enzymes, parrot company. So, but US enzymes, so US enzymes sells it to pure encapsulations.
Now, we don't sell pure encapsulations for multiple reasons.
So, that's one company that I personally don't like. It doesn't mean that they don't have some good supplements.
I don't like how they love their company.
So, but understand that even sell like some of the other US enzymes products.
US enzymes sells their enzymes to a lot of different companies.
There's only three companies in the United States. There's only three.
I'll say all the all the nutritional companies that sell enzymes, they're getting them from three sources.
One of them is US enzymes, and I think that is the purest source of enzymes.
So, those are the companies, those are the enzymes that we typically sell in companies that are using US enzymes enzymes.
So, and again, I like US enzymes products, particularly because they are so anal in their purity.
And I've told you that the EGCG, that's on the market, the green tea extract, that's the EGCG is the catacom in the green tea extract.
That is the beneficial nutrient in green tea, but you can't drink enough green tea to get enough EGCG to make it, you make it, you know, a form of treatment.
And all of the green tea, all of the green tea tea that's on the market, all of the green tea extract in every single supplement that is in existence is coming from where it's all coming from China.
I like it a lot, it's all coming from China.
And China sells some of the most contaminated products on the market.
So, if the company isn't doing their due diligence in checking and checking again and checking again and just being completely anal about checking for contaminants.
Most of the companies that are selling, we go to Walmart and things that's my struggle with them is they don't care, these companies don't care even though they have a fancy looking label, they don't care about the combination of their product, they don't even care about the product contains what it says on the label.
So, I only like TVGO, I only like the US enzymes, EGCG, now they do sell it to other companies.
So yes, the peer encapsulations, TVGO, they actually bought the ability to use the bay and two, so they paid a little bit more.
But there's other companies that are actually using the EGCG from US enzymes.
Next question. When do you think I should retest for microtoxins, might we're elevated?
And we have done a lot to clean up our house, what would this tell you? Sure, you follow my recommendations, you've done a lot, try to clean up your body as well.
So typically I say six months, give yourself six months of treatment, I mean detoxification from the microtoxins and give you six months to clean up or investigate the possible sources and then retest.
What would it tell us? What could you find when you do a retest?
Let's say you had elevated okrotoxin A, microtoxin, pretend.
And you do, you investigate your house, maybe you went to the extent of getting those petri dishes and testing every area in a house and something was found in your master bathroom and you actually did remediation and you cleaned it out blah blah blah blah.
And you've been taking different keylators to pull, you've taken let's pretend Michael pulled a pull that out of your body and then you run the test again in six months.
Well, three things could happen.
Number one, it's much better. So okrotoxin A went way down in your body and nothing else went up and we'd call that a win, right?
But that would be a perfect case in area, but that just does not always happen.
Sometimes you do it again and let's say okrotoxin A is down, but let's say Michael fit a little acid MPA is way up.
What the beans is going on there?
Well, then we know we have other sources of Michael toxic, you have to go back to the drawing board and look at foods that you might be there, whatever things you might be drinking that could give you that exposure.
So is that's the possibility or the next option is that nothing has changed, you know, nothing has changed.
You still have that same elevation of old toxic A.
Well, then we're back to, well, could be current still current exposure, could be that you really have stubborn deep toxic pathways that it's not allowing you to get rid of that.
We have to still do some investigation, but all those things are possible.
But that's what it would tell us.
Because it's very difficult to know even say we do our test on our house about something that's positive and then we do remediation on it.
It's very difficult to know that was I did I get that just because I had an issue with my house.
Is that mean that's where I got all Christmas.
That's just because that was there doesn't mean that's where I got it.
Maybe it was from the peanut butter I was eating.
I don't know.
Maybe it was from going to night church meeting that I was doing every Wednesday.
Maybe it was from your car, you know, something you didn't yet yet investigate.
So that's what it would tell you.
You do investigate other things and Michael toxins are serious things.
You could read on that page on the Michael toxic lab report on all the things that it can cause and that's based upon the.
The data that's out there.
So it's I mean that's based upon published, you know, data.
So you know, it's not something to play around with and not be serious about.
So that's why I suggest if something if that was positive, we retest that.
Do we need to retest for glyphosate?
Do we need to retest for toxic tech?
It's not important because those are things that you only have so much control over that part of your environment and that exposure.
You should already be organic.
You should already be not spreading your law.
You should already be doing as many, you know, lifestyle changes that you can possibly do.
But we're still being contaminated every single day by forces that are beyond our control.
But Michael toxins are much more within a person's control limits to a point as the other environmental toxins.
So that's one where we do want to retest of that.
So I'd say six months.
Next question there.
Some of my supplements say to take out of the empty stomach like pectosol capsules.
And others like black sand blood room say to take with food.
So I'll stop right there first.
I typically don't have people take pectosol on an empty stomach.
I know that's recommended.
I just know that sometimes some things you just can't.
So I typically have people put pectosol in their drink.
It's hard to work all that in taking so many things.
How important is it to follow instructions closely?
I think the most important thing to take out an empty stomach is number one, homeopaths.
So if you're taking a homeopath, you can't take that with food.
You have to take that least 15 minutes away from brushing your teeth or eating food.
And number two is binders.
So if you're taking binders, you should typically take that in the afternoon.
Typically take that in a relatively empty stomach.
But quite honestly, I have taken binders.
After I eat, I've taken, you know,
is it, I'm just saying the best practice.
So that's the best practice.
But that's the two most important things.
Is oxy.
This question was asked last week.
Remember, if you ask a question one week.
And you submitted it on the form, it's going to be answered.
So go back and watch the video.
But so I'll answer this really quickly.
Is oxy cell cream acceptable cream to use on breast cancer?
Absolutely not.
Go back and watch it video.
And go back and watch why your person with cancer should not be using food at the time.
What are the acceptable forms of B12 for cancer patients?
Remember, we'll try to stay away from methylated supplements unless you have elevated homocysteine.
So if you do not have elevated homocysteine that you have cancer,
what is an acceptable form of B12?
You want to take.
Hydroxychobolamine is typically the one that we use.
And uh, uh, uh,
Festival health products has a pro hydroxychobolamine.
Um, seeking health as a.
Uh, hydroxychobolamine.
Uh, you can also use a dental seal, chobolamine.
Um, seeking health as a dental seal.
I'm not sure that that's necessary.
Typically people take hydroxychobolamine.
My son is having issues with parasites.
Can he take Ivermectin or Fremendezone with that?
I wouldn't.
So these are medications and they have side effects.
You know, just like any we think, oh, this is just okay.
I am very care.
I never take.
Okay.
So, you know, even.
I'm really, really sore after guardian.
It's like, I tell my wife today,
I don't have to take two.
I'm not going to be able to fall asleep.
My body's going to ache so much.
And I just can't do it because it.
It's not good for your liver.
So I try not to do it.
Um, and I'm not saying that you can't do that.
And not saying that you can't just take Ivermectin.
For parasites.
But again, I.
Okay.
Ivermectin or parasites.
But again, I.
I would do a natural parasite cleanse.
I would use para clear.
I would use the, you know, the parasite cleanses in.
A cell core or something.
I would do that before I would do Ivermectin and Fremendezone.
I didn't have that cancer.
And I was just trying to kill parasites.
Um, just because it's all over the news that it's helpful with cancer.
And it's a off-labeled drug or it helps with.
With, uh, COVID or something like that.
Doesn't mean it's like candy that we can just eat every day.
So, uh, we should be.
But, you know, what I'm talking about.
It doesn't mean that it's just acceptable for everybody to use.
And it does not going to have any side effects.
It's just.
We're being foolish.
I think if we're going to treat any medication that way.
Just like the first question.
We can't even trust what's important in this stuff now that everybody's taking it.
What are they doing?
Lacing it with stuff because everybody's taking it.
Now they have said it's acceptable.
Once they say it's acceptable.
Okay, my trust factor instantly falls into the garbage.
So I don't trust anything that quote unquote, they say.
So, um,
Just by two cents, I would do a natural approach before I would do the medications.
Okay, questions from the chat.
I use decaf coffee for the coffee.
It's because I have a fit.
Now I have a pacemaker.
So I don't want to do anything to increase my heart rate.
So, hoping it is still good therapy for me.
It is still good therapy.
Even if you just do water, it's still can activate your bagel.
It's just that the studies have shown that the caffeine will more greatly activate your bagel.
Now, I've had throughout the years in recommended coffee.
As we've had people that are sensitive to caffeine.
There's some people that are hyper sensitive to caffeine.
They do chamomile enemas.
So, there's, you could do different tea type enemas and stuff that still get.
Maybe that is quite as good of stimulation to the mangled herb,
but you can still get that without the caffeine sensitivity.
Next question.
Anything that can be changed to prevent long lasting two weeks of your discomfort and popping.
After hyperbaric chamber.
Oh, okay.
So,
a downside of hyperbaric chamber is that you're not opening your used station tubes.
Okay.
We're your used station tubes.
If you want to look it up.
It's EU S T A T I A N tubes.
Our tubes that run from your middle ear down to the back of your throat.
So, they are a sought vascular like tube, though they're not carrying blood.
But it's a tube that regulates your ear pressure in your middle ear.
So, if you go up in an airplane and your ears won't pop,
you have a blockage of your used station tube.
When you go up in an airplane and your ears do pop, it's because that popping noise is actually the vascular, you know,
it's a soft tube.
And that soft tube is kind of stuck together with a level of viscosity.
And then with the change in pressure that copied is that opening of the tube.
And that changes the pressure in your middle ear.
So, I don't know if anybody has had the problem like I have going up in an airplane.
And your ears don't pop because maybe you have a sinus infection that I'm prone to with my with my sinus issue.
And then it you have pressure on the used station tube because of inflammation.
And then the used station tubes can't open up.
And your ear feels like it's going to explode.
A matter of fact, a person's eardrum could explode.
And that's the that's the shattering of your eardrum and then it can take weeks or months to heal.
So, opening up your used station tube is an issue.
So, personally, I cannot go in a hyperbaric chamber because I have difficulty regulating because of my cytuses, the pressure in my middle ear.
So, for me, hyperbaric chamber is out of the question.
I can't do it.
It starts to hurt.
I get pain in my ears, pain in my cytuses.
I can't do a hyperbaric chamber.
If you've had issues with the hyperbaric chamber and or issues with point up at an airplane for a couple of weeks, you have to get that new station tube to open.
Now, this used station tube drains back into the way back of your throat.
I wish I could just show a camera on me trying to do it on myself, but it does elicit the gag reflex.
So, if it's only on one side, how to open up the used station tube.
And again, this is how you could open up the used station tube of person has a middle ear infection.
So, with children that have a middle ear infection, I used to do this all the time with kids is you go back with children.
I've used my pinky and go back really quick and stroke that area where the used station tube is going back and emptying in the back of your throat.
That back of your throat is called the fossa of rosebular.
So, the rosebular fossa is in the way back of your throat and you will hit the back of your throat and you will elicit a gag reflex.
So, just so you know when you go back way back there, it's to the one side and then to the other side, which your finger is an adult doing it on yourself.
You're going to have to use your pointer finger, you're going to go way back in your throat and stimulate the top.
So, if you're going back, you're going superior towards your head and then to the left if it's your left ear or to the right if it's your right ear and you're just stroking it quickly and you're going to start gagging it and you're going to pull your finger back out.
That's how you would help open up the used station tube.
You could also do with gargling with salt water.
So, gargling, the salt water can help stimulate the used station tube and have stimulated to open up.
So, one time this happened to me when I was on an airplane, took me two weeks to get my used station tube to fully open up.
Of course, if you're trying to yawd, you could hold your nose and forcibly breathe out as hard as you can with your mouth closed.
So, you're putting pressure increasing the pressure in the back of your throat and try to force the used station tube open.
It's all about getting the used station tube open. That's what it's about.
Getting some over the counter antihistamines can be helpful because over the counter antihistamines can help open that up.
So, you've been taking some Benadryl might be helpful.
Get I said gargling with salt water. Those are the kind of things that you try to get the used station tube to open up with.
Good question.
Next question. I have a lot of cramping in my legs and sometimes my big toe.
What could be the problem besides magnesium and mineral deficiency?
So, you're right. The first thing you think of was leg cramping and your toe cramping is magnesium, mineral deficiency, iron deficiency are all things.
However, there's another thing that can be common with cramp muscle cramping in your legs.
And hardly anybody thinks about it can be tied to food allergies as well.
I know some patients that have gluten sensitivities that kind of fall off the wagon and start eating gluten again and they end up with cramping and or paid in their lower extremities.
That's not an uncommon thing as well.
I would do take backs with some salts could be helpful. Those are the kind of things that you look for a blood test.
Make sure that your iron isn't really low. You're at your really anemic as well.
Next question. Where can I find the best information that until you're on a machine. It might be on your site. I could not find last week. Zoom call.
I looked all over. So, first of all, last week, zoom calls going to be on our video site.
How do you get to the video site? Low to the member site. On the member site, you go to the zoom calls. There's a link to the video site from the member site.
Also go to our website and you can look in the upper corner. It will say videos that will link to our video site as well.
Our video site is videos dot cutters clinic dot com. So that will that will all get you to the sites that you're looking for.
So if you click on our website and you click blog, you'll see books, videos, newsletters, click on videos. And you'll see our new video site platform.
And then on the video site. Once you're at videos dot cutters clinic dot com. You can click on the left hand side where it shows the light latest videos. And those are all the latest videos that are updated.
And all the videos are separated as the zoom calls are separated with the smaller videos.
Number two, how do I get to the best information of the Atelier Robin go to our website. So on our website, you're going to see videos on the right machine and the difference between the rights on our website.
Also on the frequency course. So you all have access to all the courses, the frequency course as information on the different, the different tone.
Right for sheets. I also on the video site, I go into details with some different videos on the Atelier Robin on the video site.
I'm on there right now. If I just searched until the year.
I you'll see a bunch of videos on Atelier Robin. One of the videos says, would you recommend the Atelier Robin or the true right. And then other say about the Atelier Robin new programs, a whole bunch of videos on the Atelier Robin.
So that's where I would go. Otherwise, you can call the clinic and talk to bring it as well.
Next question, can the right program for prostate enlargement cause urination changes.
Can typically, if you're running the prostate enlargement program, it's going to the idea is that it's helping to constrict the prostate and help to shrink the prostate.
Now, remember, there's two forms of, there's, there's two reasons for benign by prostate, benign prosthetic hypertrophy.
Well, let's say there's two outcomes in benign prosthetic hypertrophy.
The nine prosthetic hypertrophy is when the prostate enlarges and it's not pathological. You need the person doesn't have cancer of the prostate.
If that goes on that two things can be taking place. It can just be enlarged due to inflammation. And that's when that right program is going to help decrease that and you're going to probably have, you know, better urination because of that.
If it is enlarged and it's hypertrophy means the cells have increased in size, but not pathologically, then there isn't going to be a whole lot that's going to actually help it.
Even the flowmax tends to not really work well, the drugs that are altered tend to not work well with that. And that's a smaller percentage of people and that's typically over time.
And then the pathological enlargement of the prostate obviously is with cancer of the prostate and that in that prostate enlargement frequency program is really not going to help that at all.
So if there's changes for the better, then it's most likely because the inflammation that was at the prostate. So that's changeable.
If you're finding changes for the worse, then it's probably, it's just probably not helping.
Whatever you run a program for a period of time, that's not your program that I created for you when it's just seems to be making things worse that I would stop running that program.
Because you might just be getting irritation and questions.
All right, thanks everybody for being on.
Remember to keep praying for everybody on this night, your brothers and sisters that are dealing with serious diagnosis as well.
And don't keep your focus on him and all times love you all. Have a great day.
Bye bye.